what i want to talk about next
is to talk about knowledge graphs and in
particular i want to talk about
knowledge graph completion task using
embeddings and i want to present you
some very interesting
knowledge graph completion methods
so knowledge graph the idea is that we
want to store
knowledge about a given domain in a
graph form
and the idea is that we want to capture
entities
types and relationships between
different entities
so the idea is that now i will have the
nodes which i will call entities
entities will be labeled with different
types
and then i will have different types of
relationships
between entities um and in this sense
knowledge graph
is just an example of a heterogeneous
graph but generally we would think of a
knowledge graph as something
that captures factual knowledge about
a given domain so for example you could
take a bibliographic network
where you could say i'll have different
note types like papers titles
authors conferences years and then i
will have
uh different uh relation types like
where was the publication done
what year was it done what title does it
have
who is the author of it who cites it and
so on and this is for example
one way to look at the schema of this
type of
knowledge graph would be the following
right paper links to conference
papers cite each other papers have
titles have
years publication years and have authors
and of course there's multiple authors
multiple conferences and all these
links to each other another example
is something i already discussed would
be in biomedicine there is a lot of
knowledge graphs where we can have
different types
note types in terms of drugs diseases
adverse events proteins
uh disease pathways and so on and then
we also can have different
uh types of relations like has function
causes is associated
treats uh is a type of relationship and
now we have this
knowledge about biology and how uh how
life works encoded in this graphical
form
and then of course there are a lot of
knowledge graphs that are actually
publicly available
and store knowledge about other types of
entities as well so for example about
real world entities you know google is
using google knowledge graph
to make search results better amazon is
using their product graph to understand
properties of different products and be
able
to to search and recommend products
better
uh facebook has a graph api because they
think of their social network interests
relationships between people's schools
they graduated from
as nodes in a giant graph ibm watson
in the background uses a giant
graph to be able to answer questions and
reason
uh microsoft uh search engine and the
company is using microsoft satori which
is their own proprietary knowledge graph
uh you know linkedin thing uh calls its
knowledge graph uh
the the the economic knowledge graph and
and so on and so forth so knowledge
graphs are basically heavily used in
industry
to capture background knowledge about a
given domain to capture
relationships between the nodes in a
given domain
and for example one way you can use
knowledge graphs
is simply to serve information so for
example if you go to bing
search engine and say you know what are
the latest movies
um by the director of titanic this is
a knowledge graph query right you find
titanic you say who has directed it
you find that person and you say which
other movies has this
uh person directed and you can directly
uh
surface this information and without
having this data encoded in a graphical
form
answering this type of query this type
of question would be practically
impossible
knowledge graphs are also very important
in
question answering and conversational
age agents and here i show kind of the
the system diagram uh for uh one of
these
uh one of these types of uh um
uh age uh systems where basically you
you get in the questions you want to
have a conversation with an agent
and the agent will understand what what
are the entities that
that are contained in the question and
how these entities relate to each other
so that it can then come back with a
let's say an intelligent
uh answer and you can think for example
of knowledge encoded in wikipedia
imdb and so on as examples of
data sources you can use for your
knowledge graph
right so there are many publicly
available
uh knowledge graph uh knowledge graphs
out there for example
freebase um then there is wikipedia
or wiki data there is dbpedia
and so on and so forth and one common
characteristic of these knowledge graphs
is that they
they are massive they have millions tens
of millions of nodes and edges
but they are also notoriously incomplete
meaning a lot of relationships are
missing
and one of the most fundamental tasks in
knowledge graph literature
is to say given a massive knowledge
graph enumerate
uh or identify what tasks
what relations are missing in the graph
so the question is can we predict
plausible but missing links in the
knowledge graph
so to give you an example so for example
freebase
is a knowledge graph uh that was
acquired
by google and google uses it uh as a
basis for its
google knowledge graph it contains
knowledge about
real-world entities and their
relationships so it has
50 000 entities it has 38 000
uh relation types and three billion
edges right so
so you know right the num the
cardinality of the number of different
relationships it's
38 000 right so it's huge and now if you
think of this
in the context of rgcn we would need to
learn 38 000 different transformation
matrices
for every layer of the gcn which clearly
becomes
intractable right but what is
interesting is for example
uh not almost like 94 of all the
people person nodes in freebase have no
place of birth and you know 78 000
78 have no uh nationality
right so these knowledge graphs are
notoriously incomplete
um and the question then is can we
automatically infer what is nationality
of a given
node or could we automatically infer
where was a given node a given person
born and this is what is called
knowledge graph
completion